today we're going to do leyland numbers
leyland numbers which are really strange
beautiful brothers
no
they're in australia they used to have a
tv show like in the 70s and 80s and
they'd just go on adventures around
australia and show you cool stuff ask
the leyland brothers is the name of this
new series and that's exactly what we'd
like you to do ask us whatever it is
you'd like to see right mo that's right
mel when you say layla numbers i think
of the layla well there's two numbers so
there's two one for each right
so here's a leyland number thief
let me just it's named after
paul leyland who's uh uh
an oxford no i see the leyland brothers
were mike and mel
not paul no
if i've got two numbers x and y a
leyland number is x to the power y
plus y to the power x the only condition
on this is that x and y must be bigger
than one that's my only condition they
can't be one no they can't be one so so
one has got to be less than
y
and
by convention
you say that y is less than or equal to
x because it's x to the power y plus y
to the power x if you
you just be double counting went the
other way around so you just by
convention you pick one to be smaller
than or equal to the other what's the
first few numbers well if i just sort of
have x and y
here and then we just say what the layla
and number as well so the first one is
going to be if x if y and x have to be
bigger than one the first thing that can
be is two
so if they're each equal to two
then the layla number is 2 to the power
2 plus 2 to the power 2 and that's 4
plus 4 which is 8. and now if i what am
i doing i'm saying y is always less than
or equal to x so if i let x be 3 and y
be 2
then it's 3 to the power
2
plus 2 to the power 3.
so this is equal to 9
plus 8
which is 17. you can just go through
them i mean you can just
you just build them up you've got 32 and
then we've got 54
and we've got 57 and you've got 100 and
they just go on so but the particular
class of numbers that
i believe are quite of interest to
people of course of the primes there's a
long way on a day like today in the
middle of summer
certainly takes it out of you
no we're nearly there now so
we'll carry on
although this is recreational maths at
its best that it's you know where you
just go and have some play around with
the numbers
i think this technique is actually used
to try and actually determine as a way
of determining whether some things are
primes or not and
because because there's basically just
this nice combination of of x to the y
plus y to the x so the particular class
that are of interest are leyland primes
not just your generic clearly number but
your leyland prime which
prime numbers made out of this
combination we've met our first one 17
is our first level and prime and it's of
course
3 squared
plus 2 cubed
and then
they're not that
frequent right so
593 is made up of 9 squared
plus 2 to the power 9 that's a prime and
then we've got
32993 that's made up of 15 squared plus
2 to the power 15 and you can go on
right 2 0 9
7 5 9 3
is made up of 21 squared
plus
2 to the power 21.
and in fact
so we're one of the biggest right up to
november of uh 2012 the largest
prime
that's leyland largest leyland prime yes
considerably smaller than the large
prime
was the following one but but just the
the way it's the way it works like the
way it breaks down is so neat is
5 1 2 2 to the power 6 7 5 three plus of
course then it's six seven five three to
the power five one two two
and this is a number which has a mere
twenty five thousand and fifty digits
you're gonna write it out for us um
got any more paper
but let's let's not waste uh effort on
that one why don't we go to the one
which was discovered in december of 2012
which superseded it and was made up of
eight
is eight six
five six to the power two nine two nine
plus two nine two nine to the power
eight six five six
and this is a number that consists of
thirty thousand digits
so you've got your the interest just
because they're fun things to play with
and that
but they are
used as a diagnostic
to try and uh
help determine whether something's like
to be a primed or not using the because
of the fact that it can it splits into
this x to the y plus y to the x it's a
an additional tool that people make use
of
which is quite nice nice yeah much more
interesting than the leyland brothers
if there's anything you'd like to know
about don't forget to ask the leyland
brothers write the post office box 900
newcastle new south wales 230 don't
forget newcastle post office box 900.
oh
you